[Musique]
nous sommes le mardi 15 novembre
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 et les inviter celles et ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département et
aujourd'hui je reçois et isabelle
jacquelin directrice de la médiathèque
de 50 ans est situé à
montigny-le-bretonneux l'établissement
avait entamé une deuxième vie après 18
mois de travaux les changements à
attendre pour les utilisateurs dès
demain vous en parlons donc quelques
instants et puis vous entendrez aussi
l'organisateur du spectacle légendaire
proposé au cabaret du goût des presses à
cerner la ville ce week-end à la
représentation de samedi est déjà
complète il reste des places pour ce
dimanche musicaux les opérettes à suivre
dans le 7 8 les invités on débute donc
par l'ouverture demain de la nouvelle
médiathèque de saint quentin en yvelines
ou plutôt sa version 2.0 puisqu'elle
s'apprête à réouvrir après 18 mois de
travaux au rendez vous pour les usagers
dès demain mercredi à 14 heures pour
nous en parler isabelle jacquelin
bonsoir directrice de l'établissement à
quoi va ressembler cette nouvelle
médiathèque quels sont les principaux
changements à attendre pour les usagers
alors le premier changement c'est
l'arrivée du musée de la ville donc
l'équipement maintenant sera un
équipement mixte musée et médiathèque
concernant plus particulièrement la
médiathèque les l'ensemble des espaces a
été repensé on a souhaité donner une
ambiance particulière à chaque espace on
a
pris le parti de
dame énergique d'aménager des espaces
mixtes
intergénérationnel jeunes ados adultes
et donc chaque espace à sa vocation on
aura un espace bd musique un espace
plutôt dédié à tous qui est
compréhension de l'actualité plutôt
tournés sur la formation l'information
un troisième espace davantage dédié sur
tout ce qui concerne
les loisirs la détente et puis nouveauté
un espace
exclusivement dédié aux petits aux
enfants accompagnés de leurs parents
grands parents quelques images là vous
étiez encore sur toutes les phases
d'installation tout est prêt pour
l'inauguration de demain oui je viens de
prendre possession de ses locaux le site
à l'origine a ouvert en 1993 on va là
aussi au revoir des images puisque tv
fils était déjà là à l'époque pour les
premiers travaux 93 finalement c'est
plutôt récents malgré tout il y avait
besoin de donner un second souffle à
cette médiathèque oui bien sûr les
les usages évoluent là les pratiques de
d'électeurs lecture publique évolue au
fil des années donc il y avait besoin
d'apporter des changements dans le
nombre de postes internet notamment donc
celui ci a fortement augmenté et puis
être davantage un lieu de séjour sur
place de travail sur place de
convivialité de lecture de rencontres
échanges rapport aux usages justement
justement aujourd'hui c'est le numérique
qui est mise en avant on peut tout
consulter de même les ouvrages malgré
tout les gens ont encore cette envie
déjà et ce besoin aussi de venir en
médiathèque pour consulter les ouvrages
ou avoir accès même si c'est en
numérique à des postes internet pour les
pour les lire il y encore eu ce besoin
quelle est la fréquentation la
fréquentation elle est autour d'eux
de 17 mille entrées mensuel et puis la
médiathèque du canal
c'est une fréquentation très très variés
on va des enfants aux actifs non actifs
étudiants avec des changes pour les
différentes familles parce que vous
tracez tout petit mais il ya aussi cette
fête du conte qui va s'ouvrir bientôt et
les médiathèques y sont associés donc
c'est un moment particulier pour les
familles les enfants les parents
toujours massés le moment voilà où on a
beaucoup de médiation des changes pour
la fête du conte autour du conte donc
cédé des moments de découvertes de
rencontres
voilà multiples et variées on vous
l'avez vous évoqué tout à l'heure cette
nouveauté dont on a encore qu'on est
encore peu développée c'est l'arrivée du
musée de la ville jusqu'à présent dans
un bâtiment adjacent aujourd'hui qui
sera situé au rez de chaussée de la
médiathèque et avoir des échanges
régulièrement entre les deux structures
des expositions qui font des parallèles
avec ce que vous pouvez proposer vous
avez travaillé ensemble bien sûr on va
travailler ensemble des gens on
fonctionnera sur les mêmes jours
d'ouverture donc pour le public y aura
une fluidité de
fréquentation d'usagé du bâtiment donc
voilà venir aussi bien la médiathèque au
musée voilà comme bon lui semble la
médiathèque a été fermée pendant à peu
près un nom un peu plus d'un an comment
vous avez géré cette période de
fermeture sachant que les locaux avaient
été transférés dans l'ensemble
commercial sqy ouest il y avait quelques
locaux de libre avec l'est la librairie
qui est devenue la médiathèque qu'est
devenue la médiathèque du petit canal
cette fois ci comment vous l'avez gérer
les vous n'avez pas trop perdu
d'utilisateurs d'usagé en cours de route
alors on a la chance de fonctionner en
réseau le réseau de saint quentin en
yvelines donc là on a une partie du
public qui a suivi au petit canal une
autre partie qui s'est dirigé vers
d'autres médiateurs dont certains
avaient déjà un usage de multiples
médias terre on a eu également un
nouveau public qui nous a découverts au
petit canal malgré qu'on soit juste de
l'autre côté de la rue et puis ben
certainement public on a un peu perdu
mais qu'on va très certainement
retrouver à partir de demain à partir de
demain mercredi l'ouverture c'est 14
heures pour pour le public et puis là
aussi un ultime point abordé cette
question des réseau des médiathèques
puisqu'une médiathèque fonctionne en
réseau et vous l'avais dit il ya
peut-être des gens qui vont découvrir la
médiathèque et le réseau des
médiathèques il ya un échange permanent
qui se fait entre les différents sites
de l'agglomération aujourd'hui élargit
donc bientôt il y aura encore plus
d'accès avec futur à travers le
territoire il ya un échange permanent où
il ya des animations permanentes qui
sont organisés via une programmation sur
le le réseau des médiathèques avec des
temps forts donc comme très
prochainement la fête du conte mais
d'autres d'autres rendez-vous qui
ponctuent l'année et puis le gros point
fort du réseau c'est un site commun l'aï
médiathèque et puis une circulation des
documents soient livres dvd cd sur
l'ensemble les médiathèques donc service
qui est très utilisé par le public pour
les réservations notamment ils tiraient
médiathèque point est-ce qu y point fr
le site internet pour justement
consulter cette médiathèque et en savoir
plus sur tout le réseau et puis bien sûr
rendez vous dès demain pour la
réouverture de cette médiathèque du
canal 2.0 merci d'être venu nous en
parler et puis il y aura cette fête du
conte que je n'oublie pas à la fin du
mois de novembre et ce sera l'occasion
d'en parler lors d'un prochain 7,8
loisirs vous le savez le vendredi sur
téléfilm nous faisons le point sur les
différentes activités sorties week end
rendez vous vendredi prochain pas celui
ci la semaine d'après merci à vous
ambiance musicaux les opérettes à
présent samedi et dimanche au cabaret du
bout des prêts à cerner à la ville edith
piaf joséphine baker qui vont être remis
au goût du jour le spectacle légendaire
sera proposé entre french cancan et puis
la danse typique des années folles
rencontre avec tony bastion c'est le
responsable de l'établissement le
cabaret du bout des prix existe depuis
quatre ans il est à cerner la ville dans
dix villes et en fait ils proposent de
cinq spectacles différents spectacles de
cabaret spectacle discours spectacle
western et le spectacle légendaire qui
est un spectacle très particulier
[Musique]
légendaire et est un spectacle qui a été
créée il ya plus de douze ans le projet
de départ était effectivement de jouer
spectacle musical sur le thème de
l'opérette et du music hall avec un
orchestre voilà le problème c'est
effectivement ces bouts de chair donc on
a un petit peu abandonné le projet au
départ et puis depuis que camara existe
on a très envie de relancer ce projet
donc il est c'est l'opportunité
maintenant d'habitude nous sommes
quatorze personnes 10 personnes sur
scène et les quatre heures au toit et la
pologne alors qu'istres de 14 musiciens
que s'ajouter aux 14
sur le spectacle
m
ans
[Musique]
m
oh
on peut y retrouver justement de
l'opérette ce qu'on fait en fait des
medleys qui rappelle le père est
marseillaise aussi d'autres medley sur
des chansons de paris et puis aussi un
hommage au music hall avec des grandes
voix du moulin que son piaf elle
joséphine baker et non du chevalier par
exemple
[Musique]
c'est l'envi de rapprocher des chansons
rétro de les mettre au goût du jour par
intéresser les plus jeunes et aussi ne
pas désintéressée les plus anciens et en
fait c'est plus un effet de
rassemblement put mélanger le classique
et la variété voilà qui sont des fois de
paul qui qui s'opposent et là nous ça se
rassembler sa satire c'est plutôt sain
[Musique]
épreuves techniques sont déjà sur la
direction d'orchestre parce que le temps
nous est compté mais mais
effectivement la la prouesse c'est
justement d'aligner la variété ou les
chanteurs ont l'habitude de chanter sur
bande et là pour le coup ils vont
chanter avec un orchestre en direct donc
cédé mise en place différentes après il
ya des décors il ya beaucoup d'éclairage
au cabaret c'est vraiment deux mondes
qui se qui se
qu'est-ce qui unissent pour pour un show
exceptionnel
tout
du french cancan pour terminer ce set 8
les invités rendez vous mercredi aux
heures habituelles pour un nouveau
rendez vous nicolas kirillovitch qui
recevra notamment philippe bihouix il
est l'auteur du désastre numérique un
livre autour des choix pédagogique
actuel qu'il juge désastreux et puis
justement le numérique à l'école c'est
le thème du 7-8 le débat pour cette
semaine à retrouver en replay sur notre
site internet en attendant les
programmes se poursuivre sur notre
antenne
[Musique]